All right, helpsters, our goal is to help me
and Grandma Gracie have a picnic.
Now who's got an idea?
Huh?
You will need something to sit on at the park, perhaps
a picnic blanket.
Ah, I hear it and I like it.
Me too.
So that's job one.
Get a picnic blanket for the park.
All right, what else?
To carry all the food and drink you will need a picnic basket.
Yeah, we do, and that makes job two, find a picnic basket.
Once we have a basket, you're going
to need to pack your lunches in it.
Scatter, you always come up with the most delicious ideas.
Job three, pack a picnic lunch.
Grandma Gracie, we have our plan.
All right.
(SINGING) We got the plan, got the plan.
We figured it out.
We've got the plan.
What happens when we've got the plan?
We give a happy shout just 'cause we can.
Whoo.
That's very satisfying.
Yes, it is.
Lovely work, ladies, and good news.
I have found some picnic blankets.
Come along.
All right.
OK.
Let's step lively.
I just finished giving the picnic blankets a fresh wash.
[BUZZ]
Oh, and there they are.
Done.
This is exciting.
Ha ha.
Oh, no.
The red blanket has shrunk.
Not to worry, I have a yellow blanket.
Yellow is good.
And here it is.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
The yellow blanket has shrunk.
Not to worry, I've got another red one.
Which has shrunk.
They've all shrunk.
I've ruined the picnic.
Wait, I have an idea.
What if you sew the tiny square blankets together
to make one big square blanket?
Whoa, Grandma.
And I know the sequence we should put the squares in.
Sequence?
It means the order in which things happen.
Grandma, please follow my commands, OK?
OK.
First, place a red square on the table.
Next, place a yellow square next to the red square.
Next, place a red square next to that yellow square.
Last, place a yellow square next to that red square.
Very nice.
Thank you.
OK, now we can do the next row.
So first place a red square--
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
If we're going to do the same thing over and over,
then we can just loop and you don't
need to say all those steps.
What's loop?
Loop means to do something again and again.
So we need four rows, so we'll loop three more time.
Allow me.
There we go.
Oh.
I know what I'm doing here.
OK.
Don't worry, Grandma, he's really good.
He is.
And finished.
Bravo.
This is fabulous.
Look at that.
Find a picnic blanket for the park, check.
One job done.
Two more to go.
Cody, Grandma Gracie?
Yeah?
I'm ready for you in the other room now.
OK, we're on our way, Heart.
Come on, Grandma.
I shall stay behind and make sure this blanket does not
get shrunk.
I found your basket.
Ah ha.
Oh, Heart, I'm so sorry.
I should have been clearer with my instructions.
That picnic basket is way too big.
This is not a picnic basket.
It's not?
No, this is a hot air balloon basket
to get to the picnic basket.
Wow.
Care to join me?
Well, sure.
So, uh, by the way, Heart, where we going?
Denmark.
Wow.
Denmark?
Thank you, Heart.
Of course.
Oh, hi, nice lady.
Hi, basket maker Berta.
Hi, Heart.
Welcome to Denmark.
Here's your basket.
Thank you.
Find a picnic basket, check.
Two jobs done, one more to go.
OK, Scatter, here's the basket ready for packing.
And here's your food ready for eating.
Oh, that looks scrumptious.
I'll put them in the basket.
Here you go.
Thank you.
OK.
Oh, no.
The lid won't close.
Picnic canceled.
Well, wait a minute, buddy bud.
Let's debug.
Debug?
Hm-huh.
Oh, we call problems bugs.
Yeah, and when we find and fix the problem,
we call it debugging.
Well, we already have found the problem, the top won't close.
So how do we fix it?
Hm?
What if we put the food in a different way?
Yes, so it doesn't take up so much space.
That's right.
Hey, Scatter, can you take everything out of there,
please?
First, put one water bottle inside the basket.
Na na.
Next, put the other water bottle next to that one.
Then place the sandwiches on top of the water bottle.
Then place the carrot sticks next to the water bottles.
Na na.
Last, put the plates and napkins on top of the carrot sticks,
and?
If fits.
Pack a picnic lunch, check.
All the jobs are done.